this place is huge
Marshall welcome to the brewhouse and
what is this this vessel is the mash
cooker here they mix the barley with
water the liquid base for the beer then
they add an ingredient to the barley not
found in most beers rice
it's the secret behind Budweiser's crisp
taste this mixture of water rice and
barley is called mashed and the next
step is to heat it up this heat causes a
chemical reaction triggering enzymes to
turn the starches in both the rice and
barley into sugars where does it go from
here I'm here it pumps to the next
vessel in our brewing process called a
lot of time louder is actually German
for clarifying because no one wants rice
and barley grains floating in their beer
this machine clears them out at this
point in the beer making process you may
be wondering where all the workers are
welcome to Mission Control here
computers use information gathered from
sensors throughout the factory to create
graphic images of every part of the
process using these images along with
real-time camera feeds a couple of
control operators can oversee almost the
entire operation
back on the brewery floor they've
reached the stage of the process where
the brew is called wort it tastes sweet
and malty like a malted milk ball and
missing the bitter flavor of beer to
find that flavor workers turn to a cone
shaped flower called hops
so we've taken our 25,000 gallons of
wort and we've put it in a big kettle
and we're starting to boil it as we fill
this kettle we're gonna want to add two
hops to that boil to start seasoning
that brew that we're making that is
really bitter
what is the bitterness for it's just
like cooking at home in the kitchen you
know you had different spices to the
meal that you're making hops are the
spices that we add when we make beer
this handy additive is closely related
to the flowers of the marijuana plant
but hops are not responsible for beers
intoxicating effect for that
anheuser-busch still needs to employ
trillions of tiny specially skilled
workers to do the most important job in
the brewery